hey how're you guys doing today I
actually ran a poll on Twitter yesterday
asking you guys will tape a video you
wanted me to make and the people I've
spoken so this is what I'm going to be
doing today and there was a few you
who've actually asked me a question in
the comments before asking me about the
crypts of Winterfell and if I'd ever
talked about them so probably about a
week ago I started rereading the first
novel a game of Thrones because I
vaguely remembered a few chapters in
there about John having some dreams
about the crypts and I've always kind of
felt one way about the crypts and how I
thought that was actually going to play
out so I want to take the time out today
and actually discuss it so let's begin
and I mainly want to give my opinion on
whether or not I believe John Snow will
find out about his parentage in the
crypts dead Ned Stark hides some kind of
a clue down there knowing that one day
John would find it revealing the burning
question John has asked himself his
entire life about who his mother was
and the crazy thing about it is the
answer to John's question has been right
there the entire time he just didn't
know exactly what he was looking for but
John he's almost had like this sixth
sense that something was down there
waiting for him
and if you guys have not read the books
then you should probably know that John
Snow has had this recurring dream about
what lies beneath Winterfell in the
crypts and the first book of the series
the game of Thrones in one of John's POV
chapters it says I find myself in front
of the door to the crypts it's black
inside and I can see the steps spiraling
down somehow I know I have to go down
there but I don't want to I'm afraid of
what might be waiting for me the old
kings of winter are down there sitting
on their thrones with stone wolves at
their feet and iron swords across their
laps but it's not them I'm afraid of ice
cream that I'm not a stark that this
isn't my place but it's no good I have
to go anyway so I start down feeling the
walls as I descend with no torch to
light the way it gets darker and darker
until I want to scream and this is when
he always wakes up so to me it kind of
seems like whatever it is waiting for
dawn in the crib
has to be at its lowest level where its
darkest the crypts are filled with tombs
of members of House Stark the cavernous
vault is said to be larger than
wonderful itself in the oldest members
of House Stark are buried in the deepest
and darkest levels and the lowest level
is actually said to be partially
collapsed and I think maybe that's where
Ned could have left something for John
something hidden deep away that no one
could find until John finally seeks out
what has been calling him and in another
one of John's POV chapters it says that
last night he had dreamt the Winterfell
dream again he was wandering the empty
Castle searching for his father
descending into the crypts only this
time the dream had gone further than
before in the dark he'd heard the scrape
of stone on stone when he turned he saw
the vaults were opening one after
another as the dead Kings came stumbling
from their cold black graves John had
woken up in pitch dark and his heart was
hammering even when go slept up on the
bed the nozzle at his face he could not
shake his deep sense of terror he dared
not go back to sleep instead he had
climbed the wall and walked restless
until he saw the light of the dawn off
to the east it was only a dream I am
brother of the Nights Watch now not a
frightened boy now do you think that
could be a clue that Ned left Sir Arthur
Dayne sword dawn down there now we know
that when Ned went to the Tower of joy
to rescue his sister Lyanna he was met
with resistance by Rhaegar Targaryen as
most loyal men who were there protecting
their Prince's son and this led to Nitin
and some men having to fight them so
that he could get inside the tower to
get to his sister that was obviously in
trouble by this time you could hear her
actually screaming and that's when Ned
was disarmed by Sir Arthur Dayne and he
was actually nearly killed if it wasn't
for Howland Reed and just before Arthur
Dayne bled out
that's when Ned picked up his sword dawn
and gave him the final fatal blow then
Ned went inside with the sword dawn in
his hand to discover that his sister
Lyanna was giving birth to a baby boy
Jon Snow
we have been told that Ned road to star
fell to deliver dawn to Arthur's sister
ashara dayne but we do not know that for
a fact
Ned's kids were also told that he beats
Arthur Dayne on his own which we now
know was a lie thanks to the tower of
joy scene so how do we know Ned or even
Howland Reed didn't keep the sword for
themselves I find it very strange that
after Ned allegedly returned the sword
to ashara dayne she then committed
suicide and her body was never found I
highly doubt that sword is in star fell
star fall for some reason and if you
guys have any cool theories on that
please let me know about it but also
Brian has also had a dream that
connected John to the crypts of
Winterfell and bran revealed this to
master Luwin he said I dreamed about the
crow again last night
the one with the three eyes he flew into
my bedchamber and told me to come with
him so I did we went down into the
crypts father was there and we talked
and he was sad and that's when maester
Luwin then asked brand why was that
brain said it was something to do about
John I think the dream had been deeply
disturbing more so than any of the other
crow dreams I find this to be very
interesting why would Ned be sitting
down in the crypts sad and talking about
John I think it must be because he is
upset that he can't tell him the secret
that he has been keeping that has been
weighing it down since the day that he
made that promise or could it be because
Ned was preparing something down there
for John that he knew didn't belong
there something that would break
tradition whether it be an artifact
pointing the John Stehr parentage or
tomb of his own even though Ned knows
that a bastard doesn't belong there
which is why John always had the dreams
of him screaming that he is not a stark
that this isn't his place Ned also had
nightmares of the crypts something
disturbs him about them which makes me
think that Ned may have reserved a place
for John down there even though he is in
a legitimate stark but there are other
things Ned could have possibly left
behind
for John define to help him understand
or even confirm just who he is everyone
that knows this story knows that John's
father Rhaegar Targaryen is most
famously known for playing his harp and
he didn't just play this thing he pretty
much took it everywhere he went almost
every time Rhaegar is mentioned in the
books they mentioned his harp as well
which is basically in every book in the
series so I guarantee he took that heart
with him to the Tower of joy and I also
would guarantee that Rhaegar would play
the harp while Liana was pregnant with
John I think he would probably play the
harp in sing to him while he was inside
of Liana still the heart was obviously
something very near and dear to Rhea
Gore's heart something I could see him
having with him at the Tower of joy and
something I could see him leaving behind
with Liana when he knew he had to leave
and I think if Rhaegar thought there was
a chance that he wouldn't come back then
I could see Rhaegar leaving behind his
most prized possession for his son and
this was something Ned should have been
aware of
even if Liana didn't tell him most
people knew about him and his harp I
think this is something Ned could have
put in the crypts for John for when the
time comes to help confirm just who his
father was but there is also something
else that should be noted something that
Littlefinger once said Littlefinger said
a harp can be as dangerous as a sword in
the right hands so what do you think he
meant by this a harp can be as dangerous
as a sword in the right hands could it
mean that by Rhaegar playing the harp it
added to Liana falling in love with him
which ultimately led to Robert's
rebellion or doesn't mean that
Littlefinger knows when it's finally
revealed that Jon Snow has a connection
to the harp that Jon could be the true
king leading to another war over who
deserves to sit on a throne I would not
be surprised if Littlefinger knew the
truth about Jon because it seems like
Littlefinger knows everyone's secrets
and when Hindman songs over in the
crypts together and Sansa said that
Rhaegar kidnapped and raped her aunt
Lyanna we all know that look
Littlefinger gave her and to me and
meant more than just what lied on the
surface
I think this harp could be the key I
think it could even be hidden inside of
leiana's tomb
one thing I was concerned about though
at first was whether or not Ned could
leave a clue with Liana's tomb because I
remember a Robert visiting her tomb and
I was wondering if Ned would risk hiding
something there knowing Robert was
coming it would want to see her but what
does one thing Robert would never do he
would never disrespect Leon his tomb or
section of the crypts period even if him
and Ned were at war with each other
he loved Leona so much I don't think he
would ever destroy her tomb which is why
I would also think that Ned could
definitely have hid something inside of
her tomb knowing that it would never be
broken at least he would hope so but
besides having gone down there or
Rhaegar harp could there be a Targaryen
wedding cloak hidden deep down inside of
the bottom of the crypts or inside Leon
his tomb or even a personal letter
perhaps I think Ned could have easily
written something or even before Rhaegar
left the tower of joy or before Liana
died they could have written their son a
will Plus leaving him the harp letting
Jon know exactly where he came from I
think all these things are very possible
plus I don't want to forget the plot
leaked also said that Sam and brand
figure out John's parentage while
they're at Winterfell
so besides brains vision if he still
needed Sam to help him put the puzzle
together where else would they find
something on Winterfell but in the
crypts it's always possible Sam could
have read up on Winterfell scripts while
he was at the Citadel which leads him to
wanting to explore them while he is
there you never know but I think most
parents assume they're going to die
before their kids or at least the kids
they are raising which is why I think
Ned left something for John for him to
discover after Ned was gone
and I strongly believe that if anyone
goes down there and find something that
it's going to be John and since Rickon
died at the Battle of the bastards John
is going to need to take him down into
the crypts to lay him to rest and this
is when I think we could get another big
reveal as big as the Tower of joy seen
when it transitioned from the baby's
eyes to John's eyes I feel like John is
going to stumble across his own tomb
only it will have a slightly different
name on it and he will be as stunned as
he was when he thought a wildling knew
where benjin was but John realized the
tombstone reading traitor was meant for
him only this time when John sees a
tombstone meant for him it won't say
traitor it's going to say Targaryen at
least I hope so thanks for watching
thanks for listening I will see you guys
in the next one bye